la confusión y la desesperación colmaron
el puerto de la ciudad de huancayama en
el oeste de Japón luego de que un hombre
de 24 años arrojaron explosivo de humo
durante un acto de campaña del Primer
Ministro fumida
alrededor de las 11:30 de la mañana del
15 de abril cuando el Primer Ministro
kishida visitaba un puerto pesquero en
la ciudad de guacama para dar un
discurso en apoyo a las elecciones
parciales de la cámara de representantes
se arrojó un objeto sospechoso desde la
audiencia la policía detuvo al hombre
que arrojó el objeto sospechoso en el
lugar y lo arrestó se ha informado que
el Primer Ministro kishida y la
audiencia no resultaron heridos
rápidamente las fuerzas de seguridad y
los civiles redujeron al sospechoso que
importaba un segundo explosivo el hecho
ocurrió en un sitio que reunía cientos
de personas solo dejó un policía con
unidas leves pero recordó el atentado
que acabó con la vida del ex premiere
suave en julio del año pasado
fue lo mismo cuando sucedió con ave me
sorprendió que algo así volviera a
suceder había muchos autos de policía y
guardias de seguridad Cuando estaba de
camino aquí pensé que estaría a salvo me
enteré de la noticia Y me sorprendió
ni siquiera ha pasado un año y me lo
recuerda bastante vividamente los
líderes de muchos países vienen a la
ciudad Así que creo que este nivel de
seguridad es necesario siento que
debería aumentarse Incluso un poco más
esto sucede en un contexto donde Japón
está en plenas campañas parlamentarias y
en horas donde decenas de funcionales
internacionales están en el país por la
Cumbre de g7